calgary um
lebron switching gears a little bit um
the nba and the union and announced
uh 300 million over the next 10 years to
help the baseball employment officers
economic empowerment and black
communities
what does that commitment represent to
you
what does it represent to me yeah i mean
what do you what do you make of
that announcement and the work done to
to
make that commitment um i mean just off
the top of my head because
before i have any like um
you know knowledge of i'm just not
hearing it from you so oh um but
i think it's um i think it's pretty
great um you know often just off the top
of my head just thinking
um 300 million over the next 10 years um
you know and uh the mbpa and the nba
have always um
supported things that need um and any
communities like the black community
where
we don't get you know a lot of the same
opportunities as a lot of people you
know to have that type of support to
have that type of help
it means a lot and i know for sure i
mean i know how much i'm doing
um with my foundation in my community
and all those families and what they
always talk about they always talk about
people
you know they don't feel like they'd be
heard or you know they never feel like
they love they don't feel like anyone's
gonna ever give them an opportunity so
um this fall is kind of in line with
that um i don't know exactly the
neighborhoods or whatever the case may
be but i know they'll choose those um
correctly but um i know for sure that
these families
whoever that they target will be very
overwhelmed
and loved by that